TSM has left the building and by the
building I mean North America over the
weekend TSM CEO Reggie announced that
after a decade-long presence in the
league PSM will no longer be Fielding a
team in the LCS some people are stunned
some people are sad and some people are
angry let's find out why
[Music]
we have made a tough decision to start
the process of transitioning to another
tier one region this may feel sudden but
to be honest we've been actively working
towards this for the last three years
that was Reggie on tsm's Twitter over
the weekend announcing their departure
from the LCS and their relocation to a
tier 1 region like Europe South Korea or
China at the time of recording I'm still
here at MSI in London it's the day of
the final so I don't know what happened
in the finals no spoilers please and
when Reggie made the announcement on
Saturday the eyes of the League of
Legends Community were fixed firmly on
game three of the thrilling MSI lower
bracket final between blg and T1 now
some people think that this was no
accident that TSM were hoping this
controversial news will be buried
underneath all the MSI news obviously
there's no way to know that for sure but
let's break down what Reggie said and
why it's so controversial first off it
hasn't come as a complete surprise to
those paying attention recently on March
31st sports Business Journal reported
that TSM would be pausing their Esports
efforts in several titles and selling
their LCS slots the following day Reggie
tweeted that TSM was committed to
Esports were planning on entering CS go
this year and will continue to enter and
exit different Esports scenes it was an
interesting insight into tsm's larger
operational plans but it wasn't
confirmation of their exit from the LCS
this news is exactly that though the
video started off with a trip down TSM
Memory Lane since the beginning TSM has
always been about competing at the
highest level and really sacrificing
whatever it takes to get there we mainly
did add a passion the money wasn't even
enough for us to buy a bed and we ended
up sending them every day but that was
also during the time where I had the
most fun
and I want to go back to that type of
decision making I want to do what it
takes to be the best now to be honest
when I first watched that I didn't
really see an obvious link between
eating from 7-Eleven and taking TSM out
to the LCS if I had to guess though it
all relates to tsm's early days when
Reggie seemed to have one goal for the
team to win at all costs TSM has always
been about competing at the highest
level
and every time we've gone to Worlds we
failed to deliver it and we've never
brought back a trophy and what that
really means is the job is not finished
this was an ERA when they were on their
way to being the most dominant team in
North America but those goal posts
shifted over time TSM entered more
Esports scenes they became more than
just a league team they became a global
brand a multinational corporation
perhaps Reggie feels that during that
process from 7-Eleven to Global
Enterprise TSM lost sight of their
original objective to win Worlds now you
could argue that the success that TSM
had and its access to Capital should
have given it every opportunity at
International success on the other side
of the argument though Anna as a region
has been terrible at Worlds I don't need
to remind you about their most recent
performance at Worlds where they went 3
and 15. and that kind of plays into
Reggie's argument here that the North
American scene is incompatible with the
international success whether it's the
infrastructure the Imports the talent
pool or development something has never
quite clicked and to be honest it shows
no signs of changing now you could pin
that on orgs like TSM and say they're
the ones who have done things wrong but
this announcement feels like TSM
pointing the finger back at the LCS and
choosing to break the cycle by leaving
the league all together this has angered
some in the scene who feel TSM gave up
on the LCS years ago and that their spot
in the league will be better filled by
someone else but others have argued that
TSM has been a real Cornerstone of North
American League of Legends brought
International exposure and invested
massive amounts into their teams over
the years of course the counter argument
to that is that although no one can deny
the absolute Dynasty that TSM have built
in North America and the money they've
invested into the scene over the years
none of that has really happened in
recent years a big question for me is
what will TSM actually be for fans after
this a North American team in a foreign
region a foreign team with North
American Roots both of them or neither
the TSM changed their roster their
management their location their league
are they still TSM we could get deep
here is a team's identity rooted in
their physical location or does it only
matter what the badge on the Jersey is
don't forget that T1 the face of Korean
League of Legends many Western fans is a
global Enterprise with an American CEO
at the top but nobody would say that
makes them American so would the same be
true of TSM if they moved to a new
region I think it's different we
recognize that skt-1's DNA as a Korean
team was passed on to T1 no matter what
was happening with management wherever
TSM goes they won't be inheriting
anything there will be no passing on of
DNA from a previous team I suspect they
will always be seen as a North American
team trying their luck in a new region
some may remember when CLG played in
ogn's Champions League in South Korea
back in 2012 for a few months in an
effort to sharpen their skills in a
region that was quickly becoming home to
the best teams in the world but that was
only for a few months and it felt like a
North American team on tour nobody would
argue that CLG became a Korean team
during that time with TSM this feels
different as far as we know TSM are
going to be making a permanent move here
It Feels Like Only their logo will
remain and even if you feel that this is
technically a continuation of the TSM
we've known for over a decade is that
actually what fans want and does Reggie
even care about that if this is part of
tsm's winning at all cost mentality then
our North American fans essential to
that and does Reggie even care about
that if this is all part of tsm's
winning at all cost mentality then our
North American fans essential to that
and of course the elephant in the room
is will this even work and lastly I want
to thank the fans for being with us
every step of the way TSM would not be
here today without you I know this is a
lot but I'm really excited and I hope
you guys are too so let's go win a world
championship we already have a handful
of examples to look at of teams setting
up shop in another region to try and
improve their results we spoke a bit
about CLG earlier also lmq coming to
North America comes to mind but there's
not really been anything quite like this
will a full-scale relocation of a League
of Legends org to a tier one region
actually improve their results on
summoner's Rift will it improve their
chances of qualifying for Performing
Arts and crucially winning worlds and
where exactly are they going all Reggie
said so far is a tier one region whether
this ship sinks or swims could come down
to which region they'd choose Europe
South Korea China they all have their
own unique challenges and upsides tsm's
Logo might be black and white but this
situation certainly isn't I suspect the
results of this audacious experiment
won't be known for quite some time after
13 years TSM League of Legends is
leaving North America I'll see you back
here when they find their new home
I just want to say really quick I've
been loving my time here at MSI amazing
games it's great to see all the players
on stage I saw Faker In the Flesh that
was really cool
um my favorite part has actually been
mean quick shot quick shot the Caster
amazing guy had a lovely little chat
with him uh yeah awesome guy hopefully I
can get the picture up on the screen
somewhere around me so you can see what
I'm talking about but yeah brilliant guy
props the shot